don't even know the difference between  appreciation and appropriation yeah I'm  a Japanese dude and if I opened up a  Ramen Shop with no experience people  would think like oh it's authentic and I  can fool the public but there are  non-japanese that dedicate their lives  to a craft like making sushi or Ramen  and then they might want to open up  their restaurant they're probably way  more authentic than I am but then people  will look at them and be like look at  this fraud look at this culture vulture  but he did way more due diligence I just  busted out some top ramen packs and just  [ __ ] boys  yeah and then maybe I don't even speak  Japanese but guess what hey they're  gonna believe me more than him so who's  the right one I don't know